[Music]
thank you
Fraser thank you for coming on spectator
TV now obviously much of the news has
been dominated this week by Matt
Hancock's WhatsApp messages the
telegraphs got hold of thousands of them
from during the pandemic and they said
there's a 2.3 million words enough for
the King James Bible you've been you've
spent the past couple of weeks in the
telegraph office going through these
messages sifting through them
um what what struck you the most reading
them the funny thing is that the big to
me the biggest story is one that you
can't actually put in the front page of
a paper I mean there are individually
there are lots of jaw-dropping moments
but when you see them all as I have done
look at these thousands of messages then
what jumps out to you first of all is
what's not there like you'd think if
you're going to tell children to put on
masks because there would be some kind
of evidence and the evidence isn't there
a whole time and then secondly it's the
kind of nervous system that you see this
is a political nervous system we're
overly worried that so-and-so is doing
the Nicholas surgeon's doing this maybe
we better catch up with her and then
Nick and Chris Whittier said look Chris
is there any scientific evidence to this
you'll say well maybe maybe not it
doesn't really matter it's not worth the
fight but Chris what are you saying it's
not worth a fight isn't a scientific
judgment it's a political judgment
coming from a scientist so we now see
when we were all told that we're
following the science just the form that
took so you get to see not so much in
the big stories but more of a smaller
day-to-day conversations the rule we
assigned is sad they were basically
their mutes quite a lot of the time they
were saying stuff they were but they
would be allowing themselves to be used
in a way for example the aren't just
techno in Sweden who led his response
would never allow himself to be used so
this was very much a political response
to the pandemic with science being
invoked as political cover and
scientists as well being invoked for
political cover would you go so far as
to say that the public have been misled
about this like you say they've been
told throughout the pandemic that a lot
of decisions have been made for the for
scientific reasons and now it seems like
the opposite well certainly there are
occasions where they lied and where the
public were at now misled and I mean
when children were told to wear masks
and corridors for example and Gavin
Williamson appeared in TV saying we
always listen to the best scientific and
medical advice now we've now got the the
message thread exactly that stage and it
wasn't anything to do with science or
medicine it was about to do with
politics now of course that's more
misleading than outright lying Gavin
Williamson we also was fighting for the
children to learn unimpeded from masks
and was fighting to keep the schools
open and for that he was attacked and
mocked fairly mercilessly by the
WhatsApp thread and that's the other
thing that I noticed that what WhatsApp
gives you in a way that no other
document dump could is a psychological
profile of how this group of men who had
untraveled power went from being fairly
open-minded about lockdown within a few
weeks to thinking okay this is what we
want to do and then it got sectarian it
was sort of language you're more used to
finding on Twitter you can now see is
used by government ministers so they
start to see themselves as Heroes as a
word they use quite a lot do they debate
who's the biggest hero and and they are
anti-virus and anybody who opposes them
even within the cabinet so Richie suneck
locks Sharma and Theodore agnewlords
they're regarded basically as being in
the service of the virus and people who
don't want to stop the virus so that's
an incredibly pejorative way of talking
about somebody of course
wanted to stop the virus but he was
trying to talk about a balance of risks
so you end up with this mentality I
think to me that's what jumps out a lot
but the government was being run first
of all by WhatsApp groups that was never
an appropriate for him
but they had in the way that all
WhatsApp groups do they take on their
own sort of psychology and this
Psychology was locked down being seen as
a political campaign and the enemies of
the world capital of their enemies was
Sweden of course and there's lots of
chat uh any any stories suggests wins
and problems that they get shared quite
Leafly on the thread
um and um Matt Hancock
um talks he has all right I I want you
to give me some evidence about why
Sweden doesn't work you know rather than
say actually Sweden's bought back fought
back two waves with that lockdown how
did they manage it what can we learn
it's a sectarian sort of political
mindset now the language of politics is
different of a language of science the
language of science invites refutation
I've come up with Theory it may not be
right so let's test it only if it's
empirically tested will I believe it to
be true so you're quite humble with a
theory you start you wait for the tests
the language of politics and the method
of politics are very different this is
what I believe I'm going to disparage
and destabilize my opponents I'm going
to call them names I'm going to rough
them up
um and this pandemic was fought using
the language in the methods of politics
when it pretended to be using the
language and method of Science and you
mentioned that that one of the most
interesting Parts I've seen these
messages is the fact that we're almost
in the room as these decisions were
being made we're seeing what people were
thinking but a very odd way did you did
you find the messages from Boris Johnson
quite interesting and sort of seeing the
way that he was sometimes pushing back
against his advisors did you think that
maybe we could have ended up with a
different policy if things had been done
in a different way if you lose hot and
cold in the messages as far as John no
he there's no doubt with the biggest
challenge is to lockdown do come from
him he sort of pops up now and again to
say hang on a minute say oh are we
really sure we want to do this normally
you feed him an opinion pool and he goes
away because public opinion paid a major
part in this uh I mean of course it
shouldn't do you should be thinking
about how to get through a pandemic with
a fewer life lost but they were you were
thinking okay we didn't want to go too
far ahead of public opinion
um so Boris Johnson emerges as somebody
who is trying to think for himself you
get the impression but he's
uncomfortable with his gung-ho mentality
of the advisors but when he goes off the
thread then you see them talking about
him like he's a problem to be managed
rather than a leader to be followed and
I think so during the pandemic I think
political leaders were given a lot of
space to make mistakes and that a lot of
people recognized that they were facing
an unprecedented virus they didn't know
a lot about so there's a lot of
forgiveness it might have been shambold
Bullock at times but they thought well
we'll give them a chance because it's
difficult do you think these messages
are going to shift that view and that
people are going to be a bit less for
giving of the way they handled well I
think I think you need to separate what
things were like at the very beginning
when nobody knew anything we had this
pandemic hurtling towards us there were
credible threats that quarter of a
million people could be dead and so at
that stage of course the only option
open to anybody in government was to
make very difficult very big decisions a
lot of which were going to be wrong
there was simply no way that anybody in
any country was going to avoid that but
you tolerated these emergency powers on
the condition that you learned from
these mistakes that you will correct
you'll think okay we've got no evidence
now but by the end of April you had lots
of evidence you see how the pandemic was
working you saw how Sweden had turned
about without lockdown you've got a lot
more to go on you would expect therefore
error Corrections taken but what this
didn't factor in was that the political
mind is such that you don't really like
admitting to mistakes you get entrenched
and in a way the bigger the call you
make the more you're likely to defend it
for example let's take um the decision
to invade Iraq on the basis that Saddam
is saying in weapons of mass destruction
now we know in the months that followed
it emerged that no such weapons were
found because they didn't exist so even
then Tony Blair found it very difficult
to accept that he had launched a war on
a false premise that's not because Blair
is a wicked man because of the cognitive
bias which affects all humans
politicians especially so so in a way
you could argue that any 12 people
plunged into that situation given
absolute power a new transparency not
answerable to the cabinet little in
Parliament little in the public would
have acted in that way
but the big question here is not to
litigate the past I'm personally not
very interested in what mankop Matt
Hancock said or what he didn't say what
matters is how to make sure when the
next pandemic comes along as it will
there will be a new pathogen fairly soon
that we've got an apparatus in place and
we have learned the lessons but how are
we supposed to learn any lesson if we
can't discuss what went wrong because
all of this is in the hands of an
inquiry an official inquiry whose remit
seems to be to kick this into the long
grass and to make sure a no politician
has to answer anything until the general
election or afterwards um a lot of the
spectators coverage during the pandemic
was critical or asked whether the
downsides of lockdown are being
considered enough whether being
introduced for example the economic
impacts the social impacts and so on do
you think that view is going to be
Vindicated by the messages that gets
come out and that you've seen as well
well what I try to do is editor what we
all did in The Spectator was to make
sure that we didn't
um Define public interest is being a
government's megaphone or amplifier we
gave space to all sorts of views
including scientists very critical of
what the government was doing what we
write articles we were very much
supported what the government was doing
we gave a mixed view I was just amazed
that I was here to find out how
controversial it was to give a mix for
you how often I'd be called up the
people saying look you can't give space
to Dr John Lee he's crazy you can't give
space to snitcher group so this isn't an
Oxford epidemologist but if you're on
but there was an idea that you were
somehow letting the side down if you
were even questioning what the story
government was doing
um now I don't I am quite prepared to
believe a lockdown might be judged the
right thing to do but what I also firmly
believe that the only way we can do this
is by an open and free debate not by one
which is edited by politicians or
censored through the prism of an inquiry
so my bias my agenda all the time has
been towards journalism and journalistic
inquiry that's what the space age has
been doing for 200 years and what we'll
be doing God willing for the next 200.
thank you Fraser
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]